let's go to the west where more than 100
wildfires continue to burn there the
bobcat
fire northeast of los angeles exploded
again yesterday
inching closer to the historic mount
wilson observatory
and an oregon aerial video shows entire
communities have been
destroyed no other word for it across
the state at least eight people are dead
and 16 are still missing at this hour
the smoky air is so dangerous that one
in 10 e.r visits
in the state of oregon are for
asthma-like conditions
jonathan vigliotti reports now from
what's left of talent oregon
more than a week after violent
wind-driven wildfires rip
through southeastern oregon loved ones
are holding out hope
if anybody could survive this he kid
scott fogerty hasn't heard from his
friend georgia tia
since flames destroyed his house and
shop in the remote forest town of lyons
both of his trucks were still there
which
indicates that he did not get in his car
and flee getting his truck and flee
but both structures were burned to the
ground
attila is one of more than a dozen
people search crews have been looking
for
these are tough tough times for us too
oregon state police captain tim fox
says the fires moved through communities
so quickly
the full scope of devastation is still
not clear
a mobile morgue has been set up in order
to handle the difficult task
of identifying remains law enforcement
medical professionals we're not immune
we know that we have a job to do and
we're going to do that
job so that we can get your families
back reunited
and so that they know that their loved
ones who are lost or at least be able to
be put to rest
thousands of homes have been decimated a
lot of people didn't have time to get
out
aubrey laughlin managed to escape the
city of talent with her two children
after a friend sent her this picture of
a huge smoke cloud
heading her way the loss is a community
right now it's a whole community
do you think talent will ever rebuild i
do i definitely do
i've already heard people saying we're
going to make this bigger and better
and i'm standing in what was a historic
neighborhood this home
more than 100 years old this town will
rebuild
it will take years and it won't look the
same meanwhile the search continues for
the missing family members are being
asked to give dna samples
to help identify the remains anthony
just heartbreaking pictures jonathan and
we hope those missing folks are found
thank you